ce matin c'est la surprise pour beaucoup
devant la porte fermée de leur galerie
marchande habituel je venais sur son
économie mondiale mais pour tous deux
jours après un incendie c'est encore la
consternation
la galerie marchande et le supermarché
sont les plus fréquentés de planoise
ce look adapté pratique tout près pour
nous pour tout le monde mais bon je dors
mal pour dépanner n'y a pas ce qu'on
veut là on avait le choix
[Applaudissements]
tout près pour tout le monde pour les
personnages et pour tout le monde pour
nous tout le monde quoi s'ennuyer pour
nous cette commerçante aimerait pouvoir
accéder à sa boutique de vêtements et
faire un premier bilan
mais pour elles aussi l'accès est
interdit apparemment ils ont bien arrêté
pour une durée de quatre mois donc ça
c'est déjà c'est sûr après est-ce que ça
va aller au delà on ne sait pas parce
que vu que le sous sol a été quand même
très endommagé les fumées ou sont monté
jusque dans la galerie dans la galerie
marchande eux donc on sait pas trop à
mes yeux c'est quatre points c'est sûr
déjà alors que les experts font les
premières constatations à l'intérieur du
parking une réunion de crise aura lieu
cet après midi en présence du préfet du
doubs et du maire de besançon